la base de un sólido es la región entre
las gráficas de igual a menos equis
cuadrada más 6 x 1 y que igual a 4 las
secciones transversales del sólido
perpendicular al eje x son rectángulos
cuya altura es x expresa el volumen del
sólido con una integral definida pausa
el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta muy bien lo interesante aquí
es que nos dan las ecuaciones de las
gráficas pero no las hemos visualizado
aún y necesitamos visualizar las a mí me
gustaría verlas para poder pensar en la
región que nos mencionan bueno lo
primero que debemos preguntarnos es en
donde se intersectan estas curvas es
decir cuando tenemos el mismo valor para
ella u otra forma de pensarlo es cuando
esta parte es igual a 4 si las hacemos
iguales tendré que menos x cuadrada más
6 x menos 1 es igual a 4 esto nos dará
los valores x donde se intersectan
resolvemos para x restamos 4 de ambos
lados y nos queda que menos x cuadrada
más 6 x 5 es igual a cero podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por menos 1 y
vamos a obtener que x cuadrada menos 6 x
más 5 es igual a cero y esto es muy
sencillo de factorizar menos 1 x menos
55 positivo y menos 1 más menos 5 es
menos 6 y entonces esto será x menos 1
que multiplica a x menos 5 igual a 0 y
por lo tanto está se intersectan cuando
x es igual a 1 o cuando x es igual a 5
ahora bien como tenemos un signo
negativo en el término cuadrática
sabemos que se trata de una parábola que
abre hacia abajo y sabemos que te
sacamos a la recta igual a 4 cuando x es
igual a 1 y cuando x es igual a 5 así
que el vértice debe de estar entre estas
dos intersecciones por lo tanto el
vértice está en x igual a 3 déjame
dibujarlo un poco se va a ver algo
lo vamos a hacer en perspectiva porque
estamos pensando en un objeto en tres
dimensiones este será nuestro eje que
esté acá será nuestro eje x y pondré
algunos valores para y 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
tal vez con estos son suficientes ahora
igual a 4 es una recta que se ve así
esta es igual a 4 y luego tenemos aquí
igual a menos ex cuadrada 6 x menos 1
que sabemos que intersecta
igual a 4 en x igual a 1 y x igual a 5
entonces veamos x igual a 1 2 3 4 5 en x
igual a 1 tenemos este punto de acá
arriba 14 y tenemos el punto 54 y
sabemos que el vértice está en x igual a
3 es más podemos sustituir a 3 aquí para
saber el valor de y resulta que es igual
a menos 93 al cuadrado más 18 menos 1 lo
cual me da el valor de y igual a
por lo que el punto 3.8 será nuestro
vértice y estamos trabajando con la
situación de algo que se ve como esto
esta es la región en cuestión esta será
la base de nuestro sólido y después dice
las secciones transversales del sólido
perpendicular al eje x déjame dibujar
una de estas secciones transversales
esta es una sección transversal
perpendicular al eje x y dice son
rectángulos cuya altura es x entonces
aquí hay una altura de x ahora cuál es
el ancho de este rectángulo bueno es la
diferencia entre estas dos funciones es
esta función que queda por arriba menos
la función que queda por debajo es decir
es esta parte menos sé que es cuadrada
más 6 x menos 1 ya esto le quitamos
menos 4 y se simplifica en menos x
cuadrada más 6 x menos 5 si quieres el
volumen de esta pequeña sección de aquí
tenemos que multiplicar a x por esto que
acabamos de obtener por este ancho
infinitesimalmente pequeño es decir de
equis y después hacemos la integral
desde x igual a uno hasta x igual a 5
déjame escribirlo primero el volumen de
esta pequeña rebanada de aquí será la
base que es menos x cuadrada más 6 x
menos 5 por la altura que es x por el
ancho que es de x y después queremos
sumar todas ellas por ejemplo puedes ver
aquí a otra donde la altura es más
grande ya que x tiene un valor mayor
aquí y se va a ver algo así
ya tenemos dos secciones transversales
para que tengas una idea esto puede ser
cualquier sección transversal para una
equis dada pero si queremos sumar todas
ellas entonces hacemos la integral desde
x igual a uno hasta x igual a 5 y ya
está
logramos expresar el volumen de este
sólido como una integral definida ahora
vale la pena señalar que esta integral
definida se distribuye es la x
multiplicando a cada uno de estos
términos se resuelve fácilmente sin
calculadora simplemente tendrás un
polinomio por aquí al cual deberás
calcular su anti derivada y después usar
los límites de integración para evaluar
la integral definida eso es todo por
este vídeo hasta luego